estelle bonjour je crois qu'il ya un peu
plus de monde qui est arrivé ce matin
sur les terrasses que pouvez vous nous
dire exactement et demi c'est un retour
à une vie presque normale c'est en tout
cas le sentiment que l'on a ici alors
presque normal puisque vous l'avez dit
paris se situe en zone orange ce qui
signifie que seuls les terrasses ont été
autorisés à rouvrir avec toujours ces
règles est sanitaire dix personnes
maximum par table
un mètre de distance entre chaque table
pas de consommation debout au paris puis
vous pouvez peut-être le voir derrière
moi sur ces images de cynthia lauvergeon
les clients sont au rendez vous certains
sont arrivés dès l'ouverture et tous
nous ont dit être très heureux de
retrouver leur terrasse je vous propose
de les écouter
ça fait du bien non pas que la vie de
quartier reprend enfin enfin il était
temps largement une vraie odeur de
liberté c'est incroyable c'est marrant
comme une créature du privé de quelque
chose pendant deux mois et demi tout
prend une autre saveur ça fait partie de
la vie sociale ça fait partie de la
société
c'est une activité quand même assez
intéressante pour moi je suis retraité
je suis retraité dont le jx à gérer que
ce loisir disons
la proximité quoi voilà pour ces
témoignages alors pour les restaurateurs
qui ne possèdent pas de terrasse
la mairie de paris a annoncé qu'il
pourrait s'étendre sur une partie de
l'espace public en respectant des règles
de bon voisinage et cela pour faciliter
à la cohabitation avec les riverains
certaines rues pourraient aussi être
fermée à la circulation entre 19h et 22h
pour les réserver aux restaurants aux
bas et au café ces mesures devraient
s'appliquer jusqu'au 30 septembre dans
la capitale
merci beaucoup et stéphane vous
retrouvera dans nos prochaines éditions
pour faire à nouveau le point